hey everyone how's it going my name's
mayuko so a big theme
for me my content my channel is about
staying in touch with my japanese roots
so i've made videos like these before
but being both japanese and american
and a software engineer one such thing
that i've started to explore more
recently
is the intersection between japan and
technology
because in my life those two circles
have only barely just
overlapped before you see i've never
like lived or worked in japan for like a
meaningful
enough amount of time but i often wonder
what would have happened if i did
because there's totally a universe in
which i did
like maybe i want to go work in japan
after college or
my parents just like move back to japan
after they had me either way
i am who i am now i spent the majority
of my life in america and i'm pretty
familiar with what it's like to work as
a software engineer in silicon valley
but this alternate universe this like
life that i could have had
left me thinking what is the japanese
tech scene like
i think like most people think that like
people in japan
and like japan itself was a country that
like live in the future
and that might be because a lot of us
remember what the world was like in the
80s and 90s when japan
dominated technology and electronics
with things like walkmans and tvs and
dvd players and honda cars
but what happened it just feels like
there's this huge
gap between technology from japan in
like the 80s and 90s
to now in 2021 how does japan fall
behind
and what challenges does it face
currently and what are they doing right
now to address it
and you know being a youtuber i was kind
of like maybe i should make a video
about this so here we go
oh quick note by the way a lot of the
comparisons that i'm gonna make in this
video
are between silicon valley and japan
because silicon valley is what i know
so this isn't meant to be like an
objective analysis of what happened
i'm just sharing what i learned from
talking to some folks and reading
articles and stuff
and so i will link those articles in the
description box down below if you'd like
to learn more
i also want to note that i'm not judging
like any person or
company or country or anything like that
like i don't think there's like a good
in bad like i just wanted to know what
is
so yeah i'm just telling you my very
subjective thoughts and uh with that
psa out of the way now we can go so
what's your impression of silicon valley
and what's your impression of the
japanese tech industry
what japanese tech meant to me was
definitely like hardware so like sony
panasonic toshiba all those companies
were
like really cool and i really liked
like audio stuff or like tvs and
those were always japanese brands when i
was growing up
now i think um a lot of
japanese tech companies are definitely
looking at
companies in silicon valley to learn
from
engineering
so in order to start talking about this
we always got to start with taking a
little look back into history and in
this case
japanese history
okay but japan's history is long so this
is gonna be one of the most like
shortened versions of it
based on the things that i found on the
internet before world war
ii japan was going through an era called
the meiji restoration
this united the country under the
emperor meiji with strengthened it
through its unification and
basically started japan's industrial
revolution before this era japan was in
a period called sakoku or like
closed borders so they didn't trade or
talk to really
any foreign countries except for a very
small few
and so just like foreign influence just
didn't happen in japan
for many many years and so because they
weren't receiving any influence they
were just like
behind in like many aspects compared to
the rest of the world
mind you this was like the 1800s so it
really wasn't
that long ago well this
industrialization led to militarization
of japan which then led to world war ii
which then they of course lost after a
period in which they needed to rebuild
their nation
they experienced just like such a huge
economic boom
which basically got them to have one of
the highest gdps per capita
in the world and this was after the
japanese economy shifted its focus from
things like agriculture
and mining to telecommunications and
computers
this was when japan had its
technological revolution in my opinion
so much so that in 1990 six of the
world's top ten semiconductor companies
were japanese
intel actually ranked fourth between
japanese companies and ec
toshiba and hitachi so yeah japan
basically had like
huge ups and downs to ride in the 18th
and 19th century
but now when we think about the 21st
century when we think about like what
technologies and
tech companies are changing the world we
often think about silicon valley
and fang and in the meanwhile there's
many headlines about how japan is
falling behind especially in technology
so what happened
so based on what i knew about japan i
had a few guesses
firstly i realized that the whole like
japan's living in the future thing
was not rooted in anything actually
technologically revolutionary
it instead was rooted in convenience and
sharing a common set of values because
of how homogeneous society was
so things like pristine convenience
stores and
on-time trains and like you know when
you go up an escalator in japan
everybody stands on one side together to
allow the passerbys to go up
i think all of that is the whole living
in the future thing but it's just
convenience
so then i thought about the working
culture there's tons of videos and
articles that talk about the intensity
of the work culture in japan
one that kind of like even puts american
hustle culture to shape not that anyone
should like have that title or that's
something to like fight for or anything
like that so things like overtime
poor work-life balance and a really
rigid hierarchical structure are things
that i've heard about
time and time again they were all in the
context of japanese cultural values so
things like melaku
night like don't burden others to being
afraid of failure as well as
risk aversion now i'm not like a
sociologist or an anthropologist by any
means so i don't know where these values
came from but these are ones that i've
seen in my own life and i've seen echoed
by other japanese people that i know
and i can totally see how all that
impacts japanese working culture
so was that it was it the working
culture was that why
ever since software and the internet
started dominating the world
japanese products and services have
become increasingly absent from our
lives
well what i learned is that japan just
didn't adapt to software as well as
other places had
because japan thought of software as
second class
okay okay this one blew my mind because
like
i feel like software engineers are like
the new doctors and lawyers of like the
2010s and 2020s like in america there's
like a lot of prestige that comes with
being a software engineer
like software development is not really
super respected as a career it's more
like something that's meant to be
outsourced
and that you do for kind of a few years
before uh you know becoming a man like a
product manager or a consultant or
something like that
you know it doesn't have like the um
prestige that we have in the us i would
say
in the u.s you know when you say you're
a software developer people like oh wow
cool you know what i mean here it's like
oh let's see
you know still that image and it's like
this blue collar
job uh at a lot of places where again
the goal is to kind of do it for a
little while and then go on to something
better
and you kind of pay your dues as a
programmer because japanese
manufacturers still held power in japan
over the last 30 years there is this
bias that
hardware is first class because unlike
software
it was something that you could see and
touch the main point is that
japanese big companies were putting the
software people
in the second class the first cross
people are hardware engineers
and those who are doing monozukri munoz
who's those are creating active things
not bits but things it's tangible
those things have to be tensorflow for a
country that's still very true to like
its craftsmanship roots this made a ton
of sense to me
japan still prides itself in its
handmade and multi-generational crafts
like in america like stationery stores
and bookstores are like
all but disappearing and that's kind of
true of japan as well but like they
still
sell lots of paper calendars at the
stationery store
and i think that's part of this bias
towards like analog products and like
paper
and i mean like regardless of if you're
japanese or not
concepts that are ambiguous like the
ones that you can't like
engage all of your senses in like you
can't see and touch and smell
it and stuff can be difficult to grasp
and so this bias against software
basically led to low
salaries and poor stock options in tech
companies
and adjacent to that are labor laws in
japan that make it really hard for
companies to fire or lay off its
employees
which you know is great for job security
like silicon valley definitely can't
offer that level of job security to
anyone but that basically creates a lack
of a pool
of senior talent and so companies aren't
even really like
trying to like hire like great people
i guess so they're not going to offer
things like better benefits or like
better projects because most of the
hiring that they're doing is straight
out of college
and so as a result of all of this like
eric mentioned
software is something that is seen to be
outsourced to someone else because of
its second class state
of course while all this is happening in
japan companies like
google apple and facebook were taking
the world by storm in america
silicon valley charged forward in
creating products
and services and companies and
technologies that would basically define
how technology
is made and at this point i think japan
kind of knew that it was like on the
downhill you know
like birth rates were declining and the
population is aging
and there wasn't anybody who could like
compete with any of these big silicon
valley tech giants but
in the middle of this there was one
company that everybody i talked to
said changed the game in terms of
technology in japan
that company was murkari or merukari
mercari is a marketplace app where you
can buy and sell your own belongings and
it was japan's very first
tech unicorn and that basically means it
was the first company that was
valued at over 1 billion dollars they
actually ipo'd in 2018
and it went really well and so because
they were the very first tech unicorn
like this was a huge deal from the folks
that i've ever talked to about murkari
they think that one of the things that
really helped them to be successful
was that it did its business in kind of
an unconventional way
compared to japanese business standards
specifically a lot of their culture and
policies emulated silicon valley
startups
so things like better pay and better
stock options and even like a mixed
language environment so you can speak
either english or japanese anywhere and
so
from what i can tell the tech industry
in japan really kind of started there
after mercari a ton of new startups
started sprouting up in japan
specifically in the tokyo area
that also emulated silicon valley
companies that allowed for a more
flexible working environment and this
only happened like three years ago
so i think it just took japan a little
bit of time to figure out what worked
for them
but of course challenges still lie ahead
for japan's tech economy
well there's more new tech startups in
tokyo than ever before
and high schoolers and middle schoolers
in japan want to be a software engineer
more than anything else
that's just not the whole picture
there's still a big part of the industry
that follows the old practices
of trading software as second class so
until there's just like a large enough
shift towards more equitable
and flexible working conditions it just
doesn't breed
a ground for innovation just as a career
um it's not as established
but that's starting to change i think
and that also goes back to education as
well
like the cs programs are generally not
really up to uh the level that you would
expect in the us and other places
unfortunately um i think that's starting
to change there's more talk of like
helping
uh you know younger kids learn about
programming and that kind of thing
um really just in the past couple years
and the other thing that
every person that i talked to said is a
challenge for japan
in many different ways is diversity they
have to look like you
or me to be accepted as a normal citizen
and that kind of
unification and or say a lack of
diversity in general in japan is the
one of the reasons why we failed to
adapt in the beginning where
people were talking about diversity
they're like are we lowering the bar
when we try to hire for diversity and
those kind of like
faq stuff which is already debunked
in the u.s there's like proof that that
is not
the right questions to ask is still
being asked in japan
i mean japan is let's just say it a
pretty homogeneous society
japan's always had difficulty in
accepting and celebrating people from
all different backgrounds
and there's definitely like a bias
towards like domestic
products and services in japan than
international ones but
japan does want to globalize and
participate in the global tech economy
and so in participating
in a global economy you know like places
like silicon valley which
definitely has its own issues with
diversity and inclusion
we just know that diversity is a key
ingredient to innovation
foreign
i just think that like new perspectives
and ideas
and thoughts that come from lots of
different kinds of people from different
genders and
races and many more dimensions is
exactly what will help japan to figure
out how it'll play a part in the global
economy
so how might they address this with
makari paving the road for
other it and tech startups to thrive
what can japan do
mind you change takes a long time to
happen in japan like
way longer than america like we could
wait for attitudes
about software and diversity to change
in a meaningful way
across the country but i just don't
think japan works that way in the same
way that america does
but japan is fully committed to doing
something about it
on japan's official website they commit
to being the very first country to prove
that it's possible to grow through
innovation
even when its population declines and
creating
a new ultra smart society all things
will be connected through iot technology
and all technologies will be integrated
dramatically improving the quality of
life
so what can they do to invite new ideas
and boldly go where they haven't gone
before
well japan's ministry of internal
affairs and communications got involved
they partnered with the japanese think
tank company called kadukawa ascii
research lab incorporated to figure
something out
and i've partnered with them on this
very video to talk about the
innovation program the innovation
program was designed to support the bold
ideas of
creative thinkers in japan to bring
innovations to life
with different challenges that run every
summer to inspire folks to take action
they've been doing this program for like
eight years now and last year they went
global so now they invite
anyone from anywhere in the world to
participate okay so i was ecstatic when
they reached out to me
because i feel like this is a really
good opportunity to really explore
what's happening in technology in japan
and also i think this is genuinely such
a unique kind of program that really
responds to all the things that we were
talking about
it invites new voices in and it promotes
people to
not be afraid of failure and to take
risks am i making it's like very big
official thing
it gives software and technology the
sense of prestige that it needs
which thereby raises the status of
people in technology in japan
every year the program hosts different
challenges that's aimed at
bringing forth different kinds of ideas
the first is the disruptive challenge
it invites anyone to submit their ideas
to get funding for their inventions
kind of like if you wanted to like make
a thing you have a great idea but you
want to get funding for it to make it a
real thing
winners of this challenge get up to 3
million yen or that's about 30 thousand
dollars in support
to work on their idea in graduates from
this program one year later could get
things like exhibitions
and patents and media promotions and
stuff the generation award similarly
invites new ideas
and technologies and techniques that
help
humanity to take a leap forward in
unexpected ways
this one gets evaluated by corporate
partners of the program who then match
with you to make your idea a reality
both of these challenges don't require
you to have like already made something
because what they're doing is
investing in the potential of your idea
which i think is so cool
also the judges for this program are
really cool there's like the founder of
ruby the programming language on the
panel
as well as many other really influential
people in technology in japan
all really wanting to help kickstart
japan's tech economy
they also have the eno network hub which
is a network of cooperative partners
in 53 locations globally this hub
connects institutions to support
innovative ideas happening in and
outside japan
so it's meant for businesses enterprises
and institutions who are looking to get
involved but yeah
japan through this program really is
putting in the money
time and effort where they need to and
they're looking for people from
everywhere to help them boldly go where
they haven't gone before
so yeah if you're interested in the
program or any of the challenges then
i'll leave links in the description box
down below so you can
find out more i genuinely think it's
such a cool opportunity to get to be a
part of something so big like this
and have the opportunity to work with
people in and outside of japan to figure
out what comes next in technology
so anyway thank you so much for watching
today's video i genuinely had such a fun
time like
learning and researching and talking to
all different kinds of people to learn
about the tech industry in japan and
honestly i'm just like really excited to
see what happens
i just think like between the rising
startup scene in japan
and tokyo and things like the innovation
program
we can really only expect great things
to happen so
thank you so much to the folks that i
interviewed for this video and thank you
so much for watching
i typically don't make these kinds of
videos but
if you like it then let me know in the
comments down below and what topic you'd
like to see me cover
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel because i'm almost at half a
million subscribers it'll be really cool
to get there and if you're already
subscribed thank you and if you're not
subscribe alright everybody i'll see you
next time take care
bye